welcome to our last session of the
second day of pipe data global 2021
my name is jana i'll be your host today
and it's such an honor to be here
hosting dr sandia right
that's right yes
in this
session so
uh her research
actually is that this before that dr
sandy is a research scientist at the
moffett cancer center in florida
her phd in computer science is from
university of bazel and her master in
intelligent system is from university of
edinburgh
her research deals with developing
statistical theory and by asian
inference models particularly to
problems in cancer biology and computer
vision
prior to academics she was an assembly
programmer working with mainframe
operating systems at ibm software
laboratories and has developed mainframe
applications
she has complete four out of the six
word model majors
impressive
today she is going to talk us about a
sparkle assigning transcripts to cells
in multiplexed images so the connection
is yours
all right um hello everybody for being
here and thank you very much for the
opportunity for me to present uh my work
here i'm sandhya prabhakaran and
the title of my talk would be spatial
reassignment of spots to cells using
maximum likelihood estimation which in
short we would call a sparkle
this was work that i did along with tal
navi and dana pair while i was a
research scientist at memorial sloan
kettering cancer center and currently
i'm at the department of mathematics and
oncology moffat cancer center florida
so
uh the roadmap for today would be uh
what are spatial transcriptomics uh what
are the images what is single cell argan
ac data and what are the challenges we
find there what has sparkle contributed
what was the reason we developed sparkle
what's the assumptions and the
computation workflow and a few results
and the discussion towards the end
so um
feel free to ask questions if i see them
i can feel them
otherwise i can take the questions in
the end
all right so
spatial transcriptomic imaging one
example is that of fish let me show very
quickly an example of such an image but
what you see here are
illuminated regions
if you can see the mouse pointer where
each of this is a cell and there are
spots that are illuminated with a higher
frequency let's say so every such circle
is a cell and this could be of any
particular tissue what you're seeing
here is that of a mouse brain region
and now you're able to actually image
subcellular regions or within a cell so
ideally with a microscope you would have
been able to see a cell but now you can
also see
objects or spots within the cell that's
the most simplistic example one can give
for this
now uh this is what happens when you
want to segment the sense because just
by seeing an image you cannot quantify
it one way to quantify it is by counting
the number of cells so you actually see
those red outlines which are actually
the cells that are there in this
particular fov or a field of view
as it's called and here i've zoomed a
particular section here
as you can see and now you can see the
the red outlines are the cells and every
dot there is actually a gene or an mrna
transcript that we call in the in the
computational biology world
and um
this is an example like a one spot one
particular color is one one relating to
one g so you already you can see that
there is um
an issue with the cell segments being
drawn for example if you look at this
region here you're not even sure if
uh the spots or the mrnas so throughout
the talk i'll be interchanging the words
spots and mrnas and transcripts they all
mean the same thing it's just a spot so
you wouldn't know if you have to assign
a spot to this cell or to the cell on
the left
and this is a big problem and that also
makes the segmentation very challenging
so the number of cells can be uh just an
approximate number and not perfect
and this image is taken from wisdom's
data release i've also given the link
there
uh this is one of the initial data sets
that uh merfish this particular
technology had out there this is a
single fov or a field of view where you
have 80 cells you have 80 round circular
structures and 140 gene so each of these
genes would actually be represented as a
dot which you don't see in this figure
yet but we come to it and murphy stands
for multiplexed aero robust fluorescence
in situ hybridization
this is just one fob for the entire data
set we had around close to 500 fovs that
we had to go through and each fov's
stats is what i've given here you had
around 4.1 megapixels to actually
process there were seven z planes d
44 channels were imaged and um
we had to actually uh filter out
specific channels that were actually
demarcating the the nuclei of the cells
which is how you would know if the cell
is present or not and for them they had
for this particular data set we had two
different nuclear markers that you could
use
poly a and daby to identify the cells
and this is again taken from this
particular paper i've been given the
link here
i want to also show another example just
like fish it's known as icy
probabilistic cell typing by in-situ
sequencing
this is a figure again which helps you
to see sub-cellular structures
this image that you see here is taken
from the interstitial
part of the brain
every color here is actually a different
cell type
in the brain you will have like neuronal
and non-neuronal cells so you you also
have like are they macrophages are they
astrocytes
um are they excitatory or inhibitory
cells so each of these cell types have a
different color
and the the part that we interested in
are these blue spots these are the genes
that actually fell outside the cell and
weren't actually uh been able to be
assigned to the cells because
uh assigning the genes to the cell is
what constitutes what cell it is so if
you have very a few genes that fall into
a cell you'll probably be cell typing it
or categorizing that cell differently
or incorrectly so this is where uh the
sp the code that we developed called
sparkle comes in but before that let me
just explain some of the important
properties and why this is uh the most
let's say fashionable thing happening in
the compio world in the imaging field so
spatial transcriptomics as we saw was
designed for assigning cell types based
on the mrna readouts to their locations
and this is also to determine the sub
cellular localization of mrna molecules
because sometimes even the location of
these mrna molecules would be
would help us identify what that
particular cell is going to do
this is now as i mentioned is exploding
after an initial period of technological
incubation
this was recently named by nature method
as a method of the year 2020. genome
biology yet another big journal has
identified spatial transfer atomics as
one of the 11 critical grand challenges
and there are large consortium like the
human cell atlas biccn the element
institute of brain science and human
tumor atlas network they're undertaking
these large data generating initiatives
and putting the data out there so you as
a researcher can actually have get
access to this and try to understand how
difficult and what the problems are with
these data sets and like i've shown
before some of the examples are murfish
and pisces but you also have sm fish
star map and
some others that are coming up
now i want to just switch gears and
explain what single cell rna sequence is
i don't know if many of you in the crowd
do know it but let me just give a quick
summary about this
uh here what we have is we're taking a
tissue of interest here what's shown is
let's say the tissue from the brain it
may or may not be tumorous but let's say
it's a tissue from some section of an
organ you know you i isolate the cells
that are there by again a huge
biological uh protocol and then you
identify what the cells are and what the
genes are
and then you're interested in what this
count matrix looks like where every row
can be a gene
and every column is a set so now you
have this very interesting part matrix
which data scientists would then now
start doing fancy uh machine learning
techniques or deep learning techniques
like that of clustering or graphical
network building etc and this is what
will tell you what are the different
cell types that are present or how these
cell types are connected
uh what are their lineages like which
cell came before the other in terms of
time series analysis etc so this is
again another very growing field
and a few words about the single cell
rna seq data this is again allowing you
to identify an entire genome transcript
homeworld and you if you i you are able
to identify what the cell type clusters
are how much they what are their
proportions and are is there anything
new or are there any normal hierarchies
that you find
uh you're also able to have a much
clearer view of the dynamics of the
tissue and the organism development
that's what i had mentioned before about
lineage tracing and the structures
within the cell populations that are so
far being seen as homogeneous
this is also
highlighted as the method at the end
2013 by nature methods
um and
single cell measurements both from the
rna and the dna level as well as more
epigenetic marks uh can are now being uh
able to be collected
so
again there are lots of addressing
efforts
wherein you actually are able to
get large consortiums collect single
cell rna seed data from different organs
of
both the mouse as well as the human
and now it's again up to the researchers
to identify what the different cell
types are how is how cells um
grow how do they
start talking between their cell types
what do they say lineages etc so these
are huge
data addressing projects and the spatial
transcriptomics imaging these atlasing
effects are currently underway
all right so now i'll start with sparkle
but i wanted to if there are any
questions at this point
not so far a very clear all right that's
okay
all right so um let me start with uh
with sparkle
what the research question was so on
panel a you can see again a similar fob
or a field of view that we saw before
with so many cells
and um
here we actually see that uh anything
that is in green is actually what
quantifies the set
and panel d is uh the same fov that we
see in panel a but here you can see in a
more zoomed in um
uh section that the there are blue uh
dots that are actually the mrna that are
within the scent so these are segmented
and they're within this whereas the pink
crosses are those
mrna transfers that are outside the cell
segment so it almost looks like 50
percent of the mrna transcripts are
within the cell and 50 are outside
so
and panel c actually shows the the same
fov but where the
they're colored now so you can also see
how different those mrna transcripts are
and how much of information we actually
use by not capturing those uh spots or
mrna transcripts are done outside the
same so this is where sparkle comes in
we actually want to recover what we call
as dangling transcripts and assign them
back to cells
so the assumptions we make here
is that we do not say that there is a
uniform distribution of spots within a
cell as we saw before there are lots of
different uh genes within a cell causing
heterogeneity
and there's a large number of
transcripts in each cell which is why we
can consider this to be as a multimedia
gaussian distribution and do all sorts
of multivariate statistics and we've
also checked this using the lilly force
test
the inputs as we are now clear we need
some
fish
fov images
imperfect cell segmentations because we
need something to start with and we also
need to know which mrnas belong to each
gene so these are already provided
and sparkle will take that in and give
you an improved spot to cell assignments
it would give you a more realistic uh
per cell quantification of that gene and
a better delineation of the cell
boundaries and also improves the cluster
assignment so i can quickly show
um all right so before going there uh to
the uh graphical abstract let me also go
through the principles first
how we actually do this is first we
generate a count matrix which is nothing
but the cells and the genes that are
present in an fob which you can then use
for clustering and you can use any
clustering algorithm of choice
next you construct what's known as a
moxon
per dangling transcript and this is
another uh figure that we've created
just to illustrate this so in the same
fov that was shown before we can zoom
into this particular section and you can
see for an example dangling transcript
that was not assigned to the cell let's
say this pink cross we draw a circle
around it to call it as an approximate
neighborhood and you quantify the
different crosses of different colors
that are there inside that neighborhood
and construct what's known as a mock
cell so this is now an ordered vector
which is arranged in the number of genes
and you can actually it's just a vector
with numbers fill in every time you see
a brown you add a one to the brown
column and this keeps going on for every
such cross
and you can also weight these maxes
based on how far they are from a
particular
spot this particular neighboring
transcript and the method we do it is by
using a shepherd's method
and then finally we use a maximum
likelihood estimation for assigning the
transcripts of the same this is again
pretty simple cheap and doesn't require
us to customize this for different
protocols and it's uh the code has also
been parallelized
and then once this happens you can
update that particular cell entry in the
global count matrix cluster and it rate
and our observations we've seen that
three plus three iterations is enough
this is a graphical abstract for anyone
who's interested and this is
like a take home
where you actually see the fov that we
started with i zoom into this particular
section here and you can see the
different cell types and the different
spots and dots that are there and some
some of these cells don't even have the
the cell segments uh segmented properly
so you see a lot of those dangling mrnas
outside
and here again we elaborate about how we
build the mock cell for each of those
dangling transcripts and eventually are
able to assign each of these crosses to
the nearest cell which has a similar
feature and that's where the maximum
likelihood estimation comes in
and then you've from your initial fov
you've already had an original baseline
gene stem cell count matrix you update
that count matrix now with the
observations you have here and you
continue this process until you have a
much clearer and let's say more correct
uh count matrix
and these are just a few examples of how
sparkle goes through these iterations
it's the same panel from a b to c just
that when for this is the first
iteration where you see how the every
black dot is an mrna that gets assigned
to the nearest cell so is the case with
b the second iteration and the third
iteration we combine all of these um
uh mark cell assignments to the cell so
eventually you get these sparkles and
this is why we've also named it as a
spark
this is again showing the number of
cells that we've recovered for each of
these different cell types that was
that's actually present in the brain uh
hypothalamus so the yellow so this is
not comparing with single cell armasic
uh merfish alone and murphy's by using
sparkle so that's basically the the
magenta and we can see that the the
proportions that we
obtained via sparkle are kind of
enclosed in accordance to what the
single cell rna seq also dictates
because this is like considered as the
holy grail uh the single cell rna
sequence and this is again another
visual showing the fracture of the
transcripts or the spots that were
covered and through sparkle the the pie
slices that are in darker pink is what
we've recovered so rather than just
retaining uh the image with just 50
percent of the fovs
sorry 50 of the transcripts you're now
able to at least get around 30 35
um back into the sense
and i also show the comparison of uh
sparkle both before and after usage on
the murphy stater
um
the
the point of here is we're actually
doing a cross covariance matrix between
the different cell types and you can see
that this is before and this is after
where you compare murphy's data with
singles and rna-seq
uh and this is the murphy's data that's
applied to sparkle and then you compare
the single cell you can see that the
diagonal is fairly strong and and highly
red in color which means that we were
able to find a stronger correlation
tightly connected clusters
post sparkle
and this
is again just showing you the same thing
post sparkle we're able to extract um
for the set of genes which you see as
the rose much brighter correlation
between the cell types which are
actually shown in the columns
and i showed the same example but for sm
fish which is yet another
spatial transcriptomic imaging technique
and the same thing here you can now see
there's a much stronger diagonal
as well as there's a clearing of
interactions between cell types which is
something you do not want to see
so we have
more clearer diagonals and off diagonals
and here is again this is probably more
biological but what this does is it says
that we are able to uh clear up uh many
of the
interactions between
genes that are shown here in the in the
rows uh to uh
the the clusters that were there in sm
fish
and then finally uh this is where we are
right now so i mentioned that we use a
maximum likelihood protocol uh that to
assign each mock cell or each dangling
transcript to the cell we'd actually
like to change this and add a prior
distribution where it's based on the
location of the transcripts and also
implement the maxim a posteriori base in
inference procedure currently this is
written in python and
as you would know as you've already
noticed the marks of creation is a
kind of computationally intensive so if
you have to blow this up to large number
of images this can get very tedious to
run so another idea another direction we
have is that of coding this up in
another language that's faster and
that's also another reason reason i
reached out to this community to know if
anyone is interested uh to discuss this
more and see how we can make this faster
and this is then another general issue
in the field that we would like to have
better cell segmentations that can
trigger better clustering and
a lot more of fancier methods in this
space
the paper is currently here you'll also
find the github link to the code in the
paper
these are different ways to reach me
and i'd also like to acknowledge our
funding sources i was partially funded
by the python software foundation and
nih was the funder for the group where i
had done this work
and uh yeah i'm this is all that i have
i'm very happy for your attention and um
very happy to take any questions also if
you would like to collaborate please
reach out thank you very much
thank you cynthia thank you
your talk was um super nice and super
different from my
normal daily basis
yeah hardcore academic research
yeah i know my pattern is in physics but
still it's like it's far from i was
lying
um i will just uh maybe
give to that in this like a couple of
minutes to write some questions that
make him have yeah and in the meantime i
have a question
maybe somebody stop sharing the screen
is this fine shouldn't i stop
like
it's it's up to you oh yeah yeah but
yeah you can go ahead yes okay
um
yeah at some point you mentioned that we
can use
any type of clustering methods in the
spiral
workflow and i was thinking that the
success of this uh clustering task
depends of the shape of actually the
data points that we have
do you see any a pattern in your own
data points in your cells
um
so we can privilege it yeah yeah one one
technique for the other other over other
one or ah okay so one
okay so i think you have multiple parts
to your question so one of the things
that both of these algorithms have in
common is that you do not have to fix
the number of
clusters
so let's in k means you have to fix what
case but in phenol graph which is uh
very frequently used in
clustering biological data sets as well
as the gaussian which model you do not
have to mention the number of clusters
so automatically it would tell you what
it is so i think it is uh already
known that we do not assume the number
of clusters to begin with
uh to also answer if there is a pattern
uh there is already an underlying
pattern in the data because
if you let me just go to an image um
probably here
right so
each of these regions
like you can see there's a band in
between there are those edges they are
already spatially um
allocated patterns
right so now what we're doing is we just
we're assigning those spots that are
left out to these patterns right so now
we're strengthening this pattern
based on our assignments so that's the
beauty of using images versus just
single cell data so in single cell rna
or single cell attacks you get what
happens is you have access to the entire
genome but you do not know where they're
coming from that's how the data is being
processed but in images you can actually
see
where they are so you are blessed by the
spatial location and now you don't have
to worry about is there a pattern there
is an underlying pattern yes you
shouldn't break it you can actually use
that as your baseline but you don't have
that in the single cell data in the
single cell rna seq data a taxing data
so
i think that's a brilliant question you
do have a pattern and that's dictated by
the image itself
okay thank you thank you very much
uh we have like three more minutes
[Music]
yes i have a question sorry ellie i
didn't see
um i will read for you yeah
i noticed that the sparkle output shows
some cells with lots of sparkle branches
and some that
are very compact
is that what you expect to see
biologically
are they different types of cells
so i don't know at which point this was
asked but i'm assuming
um
it was probably here
uh if this is the case yes uh this is
actually kind of
what you would see because
once you
go into the images and you look at what
these particular genes are
they they are very close together right
they said they were missed out as part
of the cell segmentation so they would
definitely bunch together and they would
belong to one of the cells and i
actually don't remember which one of
these is which
uh but that's a good question let's say
this is for example an astrocyte then
all of these greens would be astrocytes
and i don't know if let's say if the
orange ones were neural um
excitatory cells then yes all of those
um crosses would be
genes uh that relates to excitatory
cells yes
there's definitely a chance to make an
error which is why we have been very uh
careful and cautious and not just
so even if you look at this pie chart
here there are some that we leave out
because we are not sure they might be
very far away we just do not know which
one to assign to because it's probably
just oscillating between two different
or three different cell types in those
cases we do not assign them whenever we
assign them it would be to the ones that
we are sent percent sure
yeah
okay
thank you very much i think exactly
ellie was referring to that uh
okay looking at that one we are at the
end of our session so all right
i would like to thank you very much to
you and also nils for the nice stocks
neil as was the previous one yes yes i
do
thank you very much i also took that in
this to be here and
yeah i will stop the record right now
you